tetra chaud l'été
[Musique]
pistolet
il a fait beau il a fait chaud durant
les premiers jours du mois de juin à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
le parc a fait le plein près de trente
cinq mille visiteurs pour le samedi 1er
et dimanche 2 juin enfin l'été est
arrivé au 1er juin et donc ce week-end
nous avons eu notre premier vrai
week-end de saison avec une affluence
exceptionnelle par rapport à ce que nous
avons connu là au mois de mai avec des
températures autour des 30 degrés les
jeux d'eau ont eu beaucoup de succès
serpent aoki signer fontaine parents et
enfants ont pu en profiter pour se
rafraîchir les enfants les avis chevaux
là on cherchait un endroit où se
rafraîchir aux beignets et du coup on
est venu ici on est au bord du lac
on a mangé on fait un prix clic est
monté ici et on va un peu s'amuser avec
le p tit mais des enfants aussi répondu
aux questions de notre journaliste et
n'ont pas hésité à la rosée et alors que
tu fais avec un vieux aulas ah ouais tu
dois montrer les bonnes occasions
tremplin aussi c'est pas mal